and does a good job convincing the  officials to blow the whistle yeah one  of the stories that about him this was  back when he was with the Sixers in 2011  he's driving his car in Philadelphia on  Christmas Eve he stopped at a light and  a gunman comes up to rob him knocks on  the window ready to rob him and Williams  talked him out of it and part of him  talking him out of it was he told of who  he was the gunman apparently said to me  yeah you you do a lot for this community  and decided not to hold him up Williams  then had him get in the car and he took  him to McDonald's and had a nice long  chat with him about life and what's  going on  [Applause]  [Music]